in the last video we set out to find the
eigenvalues of this 3x3 matrix a and we
said look an eigenvalue is any value
lambda that satisfies this equation if V
is a non zero vector and that says well
that means any value lambda that
satisfies this equation for V is not a
nonzero vector we just a little bit of
vector I guess you can call it vector
algebra up here to come up with that and
review that video if you like and then
we determined look the only way that
this is going to have a nonzero solution
is if this matrix has a non-trivial null
space and only non-invertible matrices
have a non-trivial null space or only
matrices that that have a determinant of
0 have non-trivial null spaces so you do
that you got your characteristic
polynomial and we were able to solve it
and we got our eigen values where lambda
is equal to 3 and lambda is equal to
minus 3 so now let's do what I consider
the more interesting part is actually
find out the eigen vectors or the eigen
spaces so we can go back to this
equation for any eigenvalue this must be
true this must be true but this is
easier to work with and so this this
matrix right here times your eigen
vector must be equal to 0 for any given
eigen value this matrix right here I
just copied and pasted it from above I
marked it up with the rule of Sarrus but
you could ignore those lines it's just
this matrix right here for any lambda
lambda times the identity matrix minus a
ends up being this so let's take this
matrix for each of our lambdas and then
solve for our eigenvectors or our
eigenspaces so let me take let's take
the case of lambda is equal to 3 first
so if lambda is equal to 3 this matrix
becomes lambda plus 1 is 4 lambda minus
2 is 1 lambda minus 2 is 1 and then all
of the other terms stay the same minus 2
minus 2 minus 2 1 minus 2 and 1 and then
this times that vector V or our eigen
vector V is
equal to zero or we could say that the
eigenspace for the eigenvalue three is
the null space of this matrix which is
not this matrix it's it's lambda times
identity minus a so the null space of
this matrix is the eigen space so all of
the values that satisfy this make up the
eigenvectors of the eigen space of
lambda is equal to three so let's just
solve for this so the null space of this
guy's is you can just put in reduced row
echelon form the null space of this guy
is the same thing as the null space of
this guy in reduced row echelon form so
let's do put it in reduced row echelon
form so the first thing i want to do
let's let me just do it down here so let
me I'll keep my first row the same for
now four minus two minus two and let me
replace my second row with my second row
times two plus my first row so minus two
times two plus one is is zero one times
two plus minus two is zero one times two
plus minus two is zero this row is the
same as this row so I'm going to do the
same thing minus 2 times 2 plus 4 is 0 1
times 2 plus 2 is 0 and then 1 times 2
plus minus 2 is 0 so the solutions to
this equation are the same as the
solutions to this equation let me write
it like this instead of just writing the
vector V let me write it out so V 1 V 2
V 3 are going to be equal to the 0
vector 0 0 just rewriting it slightly
different and so these two rows or these
two equations give us no information the
only one is this row up here which tells
us that 4 times V 1 minus 2 times V 2
actually this wasn't complete reduced
row echelon form but host enough it's
easy for us to work with 4 times V 1
minus 2 times V 2 minus 2 times V 3 is
equal to 0 and well let's just divide by
4 now I could have just divided by 4
here which might have made it maybe I
skipped a step if you divide by 4 you
get V 1 minus 1/2
v2 minus 1/2 v3 is equal to 0 or V 1 is
equal to 1/2 V 2 plus 1/2 v3 just added
these guys to both sides of the equation
or we could say if we say that let's say
that V 2 is equal to I don't know it's
equal to I'm just going to put some
random number a and V 3 is equal to B
then we can say and then V 1 would be
equal to 1/2 a plus 1/2 B we can say
that the eigenspace the eigenspace for
lambda is equal to 3 is the set of all
vectors v1 v2 v3 that are equal to a
times a times v2 is a right so v2 is
equal to a times 1 v3 has no ay in it so
it's a times 0 nowsave v1 plus B times
v2 is just a right v2 has no B in it so
it's 0 V 3 is 1 times 0 times a plus 1
times B and then V 1 is 1/2 is 1/2 a
plus 1/2 B 1/2 and 1/2 for any a and B I
could rino such that a and B are members
of the reals just to be a little bit
formal about it so that's our eigen any
any vector in that may that satisfies
this is an eigen vector and they're the
eigenvectors that correspond to the
eigenvalue lambda is equal 3 so if you
apply the matrix transformation to any
of these vectors you're just going to
scale them up by a by 3 or you could say
let me write it this way the eigenspace
for lambda is equal to 3 is equal to the
span all of the potential linear
combinations of this guy in that guy so
1/2 1 0 and and 1/2 0 1 so
that's the that's what only one of the
eigenspaces that's the one that
corresponds to lambda is equal to three
let's do the one that corresponds to
lambda is equal to minus three so if
lambda is equal to minus three I'll do
it up here I think I'm gonna paste
lambda is equal to minus three this
matrix becomes this matrix becomes I'll
do the diagonals minus 3 plus 1 is minus
2 minus 3 minus 2 is minus 5 minus 3
minus 2 is minus 5 and all the other
things don't change minus 2 minus 2 1
minus 2 minus 2 and 1 and then that
times vectors and the eigenspace that
corresponds to lambda is equal to minus
3
is going to be equal to zero I'm just
applying this equation right here which
we just derived from that one over there
so what is so we're looking the
eigenspace that corresponds to lamp is
equal to minus 3 is the null space this
matrix right here are all the vectors
that satisfy this equation so what is
the null space of this is the same thing
as a null space of this in reduced row
echelon form so let's put it in reduced
row echelon form so let's the first
thing I want to do I'm going to keep my
first row the same I'm going to write a
little bit smaller than I normally do
because I think I'm going to run out of
space so minus 2 minus 2 minus 2 and
then actually let me just do it this way
I will skip some steps let's just divide
the first row by minus 2 so we get 1 1 1
and then let's replace this second row
with the second row plus this version of
the first row so this guy plus that guy
is 0 minus 5 plus minus or let me say it
this way let me replace it with let me
replace it with the second with the
first row minus the second row so minus
2 minus minus 2 is 0 minus 2 minus minus
5 is plus 3 and then minus 2 minus 1 is
minus 3 minus 3 and let me do the last
row just in a different color for fun
and I'll do the same thing under this
row minus this row so minus 2 minus
minus 2 is 0 minus 2 plus 2 minus 2
minus 1 is minus 3 and then we have
minus 2 minus minus 5 so that's minus 2
plus 5 so that is 3 now let me replace
now let me in now let me replace and
I'll do it in 2 steps so this is 1 1 1
I'll just keep it like that and actually
well let me just keep it like that and
then let me replace my third row with my
third row plus my second row I'll just
zero out you sad these terms these all
just become 0 that guy got zeroed out
and let me take my second row and divide
it by 3 so this becomes 0
1-1 and then I'm almost there I'm almost
there I'll do it in orange so let me
replace my first row with my first row -
my second row so this becomes 1 0 and
then 1 minus minus 1 is 2 1 minus minus
1 is 2 and then the second row is 0 1
minus 1 and then the last row is 0 0 0
so any V that satisfies this equation
will also satisfy this guy that is that
this guy's null space is going to be in
the null space of that guy in reduced
row echelon form so V 1 V 2 V 3 is equal
to 0 0 0 let me move this because I've
officially run out of space so let me
move this lower down where I have some
free real estate let me move it down
here this this is corresponds to lambda
is equal to minus 3
this was lambda is equal to minus 3 just
to make us you know it's not related to
this stuff right here so what are all of
the v1 v2 and v3 that satisfy this so if
we say that v3 let's say that v3 is
equal to v3 is equal to t if v3 is equal
to T then what do we have here we have
this tells us that v2 minus v3 is equal
to 0 so it tells us that v2 minus v3
right v2 is what 0 times v1 plus v2
minus v3 is equal to 0 or that v2 is
equal to v3 which is equal to T that's
what that second equation tells us and
then the third equation tells us or the
top equation tells us v1 times 1 so v1
plus 0 times v2 plus 2 times v3 plus two
times v3 is equal to 0 or V 1 is equal
to minus 2 V 3 which is equal to minus 2
times T so the eigen space
that corresponds to lambda is equal to
minus three is equal to the set of all
the vectors V 1 V 2 and V 3
where well it's equal to T times T times
V 3 is just T right we does V 3 was just
T V 2 also just ends up being T so 1
times T and V 1 is minus 2 times t minus
2 times T 4 T is any real number or
another way to say it is that the
eigenspace for lambda is equal to minus
3 is equal to is equal to the span or
lamb I wrote that's really messy for
lambda is equal to minus 3 is equal to
the span of the vector of the vector
minus 2 1 and 1 just like that
and looks interesting because if you
take this guy and dotted with either of
these guys I think you get zeroes that
is that definitely the case if you take
minus 2 times one half you get a minus 1
there and then you have a plus 1 that's
0 and then minus 2 times one half yeah
you dot with either of these guys you
get zero so this line is orthogonal to
that plane very interesting so let's
just graph it just so we have a good
visualization of what we're doing so you
know we had that 3 by 3 matrix a it
represents some transformation in r3 and
it has two eigenvalues and each of those
have a corresponding eigen space so the
eigenspace that corresponds to the
eigenvalue 3 is a plane in r3 it's a
plane in r3 so this is the eigenspace
for lambda is equal to 3 and it's the
span of these two vectors right there so
you know if I draw maybe they're like
that just like that and then the
eigenspace for lambda is equal to minus
3 is a line it's a line that's
perpendicular to this plane it's a line
like that
it's the span of this guy maybe if I
draw that vector that vector might look
something like this
it's the span of that guy so what this
telling this is this
right here is the eigenspace for lambda
is equal to minus three so what that
tells us just to make sure we're you're
inter interpreting our eigen values and
eigen spaces correctly is look you give
me any eigenvector
you give me any vector in this you give
me any vector right here let's say that
is vector X if I apply the
transformation if I'm multiply it by a
I'm going to have three times that
because it's in the eigenspace for
lambda is equal to three so if I were to
apply a times X a times X would be just
three times that so that would be a
times X that's what it tells me this
would be true for any of these guys if
this was X you took a times X is going
to be three times as long now these guys
over here if you have some vector in
this eigen space that corresponds to
lambda is equal to three and you apply
the transformation let's say that this
is X right there if you took the
transformation of X it's going to make
it three times longer and in the
opposite direction it's still going to
be on this line but just in so it's
going to go down like this and that
would be a times X it'd be the same it'd
be three times this length but in the
opposite direction because it
corresponds to lambda is equal to minus
three so anyway we've I think made a
great achievement we've not only figured
out the eigenvalues for a three by three
matrix we now have figured out all of
the eigen vectors which are there's
infinite number but they represent two
eigen spaces that correspond to those
two eigenvalues four minus three and
three see you in the next video